am i not millennial anymore have i
passed that but gen z is the one before
younger yeah jules
it's jewels
there's one before
no no jules is the girl that lives
upstairs we have a teenager living
upstairs oh i have a human trafficking
business
okay
now the range rover makes sense i see
flashy car movie producer oh we've been
down that road okay
millennials ages 23 to 38. yeah 38 being
a millennial is
a millennial you work at h r block
what am i
you're um generation x baby it just
sounds better it does sound cool yeah
generation x is like [ __ ] you you don't
mean i want to spit in your [ __ ]
but it's not mean it's like it's lube
what are you eating
no spinach it sounded very aggressive
and no it doesn't it's a nice thing for
men to do thank you that's all who wants
to dry bang a chick yeah well you could
just lick it no you could just very
nicely moisturize it that's the same
thing as spitting it i know but would
you rather like just like look at me
right yeah bro we're looking just look
at me right would you i mean
why do you think i'm crossing
would you rather
you know i mean lick right yeah or
i would oh okay
it ups the it's like the nos button
you're like [ __ ] straightforward
you know yeah yeah yeah in fact when i
first so licking is like de la soul and
then like spitting is nice
yeah
yeah if i were to you know go be on a
first date with a guy and and i saw him
like spit on the sidewalk but it was a
very weak spit the likelihood of me
finding him attractive is very low
i need some you know some force behind
that yeah i always thought in the movies
when they spin to the tins and like ting
i was like those guys could [ __ ] my
girlfriend
i'll be a cook for that guy
because they make that noise
yeah that's dope so good i had a kid
spit in my face as a kid
just
that isn't a dollar you were oh yeah a
kid or no no i was a kid as well okay if
it happened as an adult and a kid spit
on my face we'd have problems
like if a kid walked up to you as your
age 29 what would you do and spit on my
face and he's just spitting it hey [ __ ]
you trevor
if you knew who i was i'd be stoked
yeah that's my demo right
but if you didn't like random yeah what
do you what do you do you can't hit the
kid i wouldn't hit him but i would just
like yell something that'd be that like
he'll find out later in life you know
right like i don't know i don't know
it's so mean yeah it's something like
stick with him right well it would
depend on what he looks like
yeah he can't just you know i mean if
he's a good looking kid but if he had
some things i'm not gonna get in i would
just like try to break their family down
like psycho psychology yeah you know
psychologically your dad doesn't
actually love your mom and that's why he
comes home at three he's been banging
hookers out in portland yeah yeah yeah
like or your mom wanted to abort you she
told me yourself yeah like one of those
that way he's like yeah whatever then
he's like at the dinner table and he's
like oh liver again maybe she did want
to abort me
wait you're not no is liver not good is
liver not something we we like
i wouldn't say it's great
liver like the organ
yeah are you asian are you not asian
what do you mean liver why'd you is a
liver not gonna chicken liver to eat
uh do you eat livers no yeah yeah you
either
yeah yeah i've had chicken food
kidney what is it i've had chicken foot
before yeah chicken feet like that's
very